THAT'S FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
SCIENCE SAYS OUR STUDENTS CAN'T
GO BACK TO THEIR NORMAL ROUTINE.
THEREFORE I AM SUSPENDING IN
PERSON LEARNING IN SCHOOLINGS
FOR REMAINDER OF THE 2019-202
SCHOOL YEAR.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE SCHOOL
REMAIN CLOSED FOR REST OF OF THE
YEAR.
THEY MUST BEGIN THE SCHOOL YEAR
THIS FALL, THROUGH DISTANCE
LEARNING WE HAVE TENDENCY
AMERICANS WHO LIVE SUCH FAST
PACED LIVES TO WANT MOVER ON TOO
FAST FROM CRISIS.
WHAT DO I MEAN BY THAT?
ISN'T RESILIENT APPROACH
CARRYING ON GOOD THING?
INTEREST RATE TO BE AN
ENCOURAGED.
WHEN WE TALKING THOUGH ABOUT
SOMETHING AS PROFOUNDLY DAMAGING
AS GOVERNMENT PANDEMIC LOCKDOWN
MANDATE, THE ANSWER IS, YES AND
NO.
NO WE SHOULD NOT WOL LOW IN
LINGERING MISERY WE CAN'T CHANGE
BUT YES WE NEED ACCOUNTABLE TO
ENSURE IN NEVER, EVER HAPPENS
AGAIN.
AND THAT MEANS HOLDS
ACCOUNTEDABLE ANY ONE AND ANY
ORGANIZATION THAT PUSHED
POLICIES THAT WERE NEVER
GROUNDED IN SCIENCE.
AND CERTAINLY NOT PERMISSIBLE
UNDER CONSTITUTION.
NOW ALMOST IMMEDIATELY WHEN
LOCKDOWN BEGAN IN FEDERAL LEVEL
AND THEN TRICKLING INTO STATE,
ANGLE WAS FORCE FOR PROTECTING
VULNERABLE.
AND ALSO FOR REOPENING THE
GOVERNMENT AND ESPECIALLY THE
SCHOOLS.
THERE ARE DEVASTATION
CONSEQUENCES OF KEEPING CHILDREN
AWAY FROM SCHOOL FOR EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME.
FROM MEDICAL AND COMMON SENSE
STAND POINT DECISION PUT KIDS
BACK INTO SCHOOL SHOULD BE SLAM
DUNK YES.
THEY DON'T DO WELL AT ALL
WITHOUT IN PERSON SCHOOLING.
THE DAMAGE ACADEMIC DECLINE
DEPREEGS ISOLATION SUICIDE
ADDICTION.
ABUSE.
AND WE TRIED BLUE STATES THAT
KEEPING SCHOOLS CLOSED AND
SHUTTING DOWN ATHLETIC ALL OF
GYMS THAT WAS GOING COME BACK
BITE THEM AND WE WERE RIGHT.
POLITICALLY SPEAKING VIRGINIA
GOVERNOR'S RACE SAN FRANCISCO
SCHOOL BOARD WIPE OUT OF
DEMOCRATS DFW RACES EARLIER THIS
WEEK.
ALL POINT TO COMING HUGE LOSSES
OF PRO CLOSURE DEMOCRATS IN
NOVEMBER.
AND NOW MORE MAN TWO YEARS
LATER, DEMOCRAT WHO ADVOCATED
FORCLOSURE ALL OF THAT STUFF,
THEY ARE SEEING FALL OUT FOR
THEMSELVES.
TWO LEFT LEANING MEDIA OUT LET'S
PUBLISHED OPINION PIECES
ADMITTING STARK TERMS THE
HORRIBLE LINGER GOING AFFECTS
LOCKDOWNS ON OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
MARY RUNNING NOTED MUCH BLUE
AMERICA WHICH SCHOOLS REMOTE,
HYBRID BRING FOR 2020 CONDUCT
DOING UNPRECEDENTED SOCIAL,
PERMENT ON CHILDREN.
RESORTING LENGTHY SCHOOL
CLOSURES FOR MILLIONS.
TACTIC NOT USED DURING OTHER
NATIONAL EMERGENCIES OR PREVIOUS
PANDEMICS WELL NOW RESULTS ARE
IN FROM SOCIAL HE CAN PERMANENT
AND THEY HAVE VERY, VERY BAD
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORTED THEM ARE
FINALLY READY TALK ABOUT IT.
SHE CITED DAVID "NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORT THAT MAIN AFFECTS HYBRID
REMOTE INSTRUCTION ARE NEGATIVE.
AND IMPLYING EVEN LOW POVERTY
HIGH INCOME SCHOOLS, STUDENTS
FELL BEHIND GROWTH EXPECTS WHEN
THEIR SCHOOLS WENT REMOTE OR
HYBRID.
BUT THE CONSEQUENCES WERE EVEN
WORSE FOR LOWER INCOME SCHOOLS.
AND AS SPEAKING OF TIMES EVEN
MORE CHILLING EXAMINATION OF HOW
THIS NOW MANIFESTING ITSELF AT
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES, YOU
GOT PERFORMING POORLY.
MANY ARE NOT EVEN SHOWING UP FOR
ON TIME.
AND WHEN CLASS RETURN MAINLY IN
PERSON IN FALL OF 2021, STUDENT
PERFORMANCE DIDN'T BOUNCE BACK.
THE PROBLEM NOT ONLY STUDENTS
LEARNED POORLY ON LINE BUT ALSO
WHEN THEY GO THROUGH A YEAR OF
MORE REMOTE CLASSES THEY DO
DEVELOP HABITS.
AND NOW MEANWHILE, WHILE ZOMBIE
PHENOMENON APPEARED MANY ELITE
TOP TIER SCHOOLS, ONE SMALL
CATHOLIC COLLEGE IN TEXAS WAS
FARING REALLY WELL.
UNIVERSITY OF DALLAS.
KIDS WERE BACK IN SCHOOL IN
FALL.
OF 202 THEY WERE PRETTY MUCH ON
TRACK.
AND THEY WERE ENGAGED DOING WHAT
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING
WHICH IS LEARNING.
ONE PROFESSOR DESCRIBED THINKING
THIS WAY.
THEY BALANCED IMMEDIATE HEALTH
IMPERATIVE WITH OTHER IMPERATIVE
ARE NO LESS IMPORTANT.
IMPORTANT MENTAL HEALTH
IMPORTANCE OF FRIENDSHIP
IMPORTANCE OF FISCAL PROXIMITY
TO OTHER HUMAN BEINGS FOR MOST
OF THEM.
IF ONLY THE TEACHER UNION IF
ONLY THEY HAD POSSESSED SUCH
WISDOM.
AND FOR THEM ALL ABOUT
POLITICALLY GONES AND PAYBACK.
HECK CONGRESS HOUSE
REPRESENTATIVES WE ARE STILL
BACK NOT BACK IN SESSION.
PELOSI STILL ALLOWING HOUSE
REPRESENTATIVE TO VOTE REMOTELY
SHE ONCE EXTENDED THAT PANDEMIC
PROXY VOTING RULES THROUGH THE
PERIOD OF JUNE OF 2008TH.
IT IS NEVER GOING TO END.
MUCH FEDERAL WORKFORCE ACROSS
EVERY DEPARTMENT ACROSS EVERY
AGENCY IT IS STILL NOT BACK IN
OFFICE.
THIS IS A COMPLETE SCANDAL.
AND.
AND SOME MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
TRYING TO FORCE EMPLOYEES OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BACK TO THE
SAME WORK RULES THAT THEY HAD IN
DECEMBER OF 2019.
LIKE ANDY BUSINESS WITH HIS
RETURN TO WORKABILITY.
NASHLY FEDERAL WORKERS THEY WANT
TO STAY HOME JUST LIKE SO MANY
TEACHERS DID BEFORE THEY WERE
FORCED BACK INTO CLASSROOM.
BUT STUDENTS SUFFERED.
AND NOW TAXPAYERS ARE SUFFERING
AS WELL.
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES UNION THEY
DON'T CARE.
JUST LIKE RANEE AFT DIDN'T CARE
EVEN THOUGH NOW SHE PRETENDING
TO.
OUR KIDS ARE IN CRISIS.
AND WE HAVE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
BEFORE COVID.
BUT FOR TWO YEARS DISRUPTION,
TWO YEARS OF LOOKING AT THE
SCREENS.
TWO YEARS OF NOT HAVING A NORMAL
KIND OF ROUTINE AND RHYTHM.
OKAY.
THROWING SOMETHING AT THE
SCREEN.
OKAY.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
SHE KIDDING ME?
YOUR RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
SWEETIE.
STAYING AT HOME PRO UNION
DEMOCRATS PREFER I HAVE GOOD
NEWS FOR MANY OF THEM.
VOTERS WILL ACCEPTING YOU HOME
COME NOVEMBER.
RET TRI BOWS ON